hi guys
oh look apple store I'm in Chicago right
now and I'm actually on my way to a
conference and wow you guys can't see
this but right now displays me out in
the store they have like issues she
swears the represent different
applications on the iPhone
it's really cool I'll take a picture and
I'll post it anyway sort of say hi and I
just realized I think I've worn this
shirt before you can tell me which Apple
Store video I've worn this shirt in I'll
send your t-shirt yeah that's all I got
okay um triangle Apple Store
I just see an Apple store tour 2008 I
don't think I'm gonna be able to make it
to all the office doors in 2008 might
have to go to 2009 okay